they began arriving on saturday dozens
of trucks and other vehicles lining up
at southern alberta's busy canada u.s
border crossing what we'd like to see
is everything go back to the way it was
in 2019 before
all this started all the mandates lifted
all the restrictions gone
and that put into legislation so this
does not happen again over the weekend
an alberta government mla joined the
protests sharing on social media i
brought the grandkids down to the coots
border today to show them the importance
of standing up for freedom and liberty
this is going to be an issue that our
caucus needs to talk about
i think disappointed that grant hunter
made the decision to go there and
participate in that illegal blockade the
blockade must end immediately kenny said
on social media sunday before adding
operational enforcement decisions are
the responsibility of police services
rcmp say they're working to bring about
a peaceful resolution but protesters
aren't backing down it's important to
note that not every truck stuck in this
lineup is a part of the protest in fact
we spoke with a number of truckers who
are now stuck here and just want to get
home i'm stuck like a part of the 3d
no shower nothing anything do you feel
safe
no no no anybody no no safe carrying
loads of goods intended for calgary
grocery stores several truckers tell
global news they feel like hostages
caught up in a blockade that does not
represent them i'm carrying produce from
sacramento california
to calgary i cross the border on
saturday
i'm over 40 hours right now here
stack and uh
just cross the border if they have a
freedom not to vaccinate where's my
freedom i support them but i'm the one
who stuck here who's suffering me
by monday afternoon some of the truckers
trapped in the protest were allowed to
return to calgary via a back road unable
to complete their american-bound
deliveries as originally planned
rcmp say they continue to negotiate with
protest organizers to try and find a
peaceful resolution to this border
blockade but police warn that if one
cannot be found they will move in and
remove protesters by force if required
donna
all right heather yoricks wes thanks